ja willkommen zur aktuellen Sendung in
der wir es heute mit dem politischen
Thema des Kontraktualismus zu tun haben
Kontraktualismus ist eine sehr
einflussreiche Position innerhalb der
politischen Philosophie Kontraktualismus
dieses Wort kommt vom Wort contract das
kennen wir das heißt so viel wie Vertrag
und wir haben jetzt schon einige
Positionen der politischen Philosophie
der Frage nach der Konzeption von
politischen Systemen kennengelernt wir
haben uns befasst mit dem Liberalismus
da mache ich oben rechts ein Link hinein
wir haben uns aber auch mit der
Gegenposition zum Liberalismus befasst
das war die Position des Kommunitarismus
auch da mache ich oben rechts ein
Videolink hinein Kommunitarismus besagt
im Gegensatz zum liberalism mus dass
nicht das einzige Individuum die Basis
für die Politik für die politische
Systematik darstellt sondern die
Gemeinschaft aus der heraus wir erst
Individuen sein können und überhaupt
erst auch uns als Individuen entwickeln
können es gibt noch andere Positionen es
gibt noch die Position des
Egalitarismus dazu zählt z.B John RWS da
mache ich auch oben rechts einen Link
hinein John RWS hat aber auch wiederum
sehr viele Ähnlichkeiten zum
Kontraktualismus wo es eben um die
Verträge geht die Frage die jetzt heute
im Zentrum steht ist die wie können wir
gewährleisten dass das Individuum trotz
Gesellschaftsvertrag immer noch autonom
ist und nicht wie bei Thomas horbes alle
seine Freiheit an den Staat übergibt bei
Thomas horbes hatten wir gesehen der
leviatan wird nur dadurch so mächtig
dass jedes Individuum auf sein eigenen
Freiheiten zu seinen Gunsten verzichtet
wir können nur diese politische
Stabilität erhalten nach Thomas HS in
diesem starken stat des lbiatan wenn wir
selbst unsere Freiheit aus eigen
Entscheidung abgeben delegieren an
dieses übergeordnete politische System
jetzt kann man sich fragen besteht nicht
auch die Möglichkeit sowas wie
Liberalismus individuelle Rechte
Entfaltung des Individuums Autonomie auf
Seiten des idums zu vereinbaren mit
einem Staat der mächtig und
funktionsfähig ist und diese Frage hat
sich Jean-Jacques Rousseau gestellt in
seiner Schrift der
Gesellschaftsvertrag wir sehen diese
Schrift ist schon recht alt aus dem 18
Jahrhundert
und wir sehen hier im Titel du
contontrastozial oder die Prinzipien des
politischen recht es geht also auch um
die Frage nach dem Recht was in
politischen Systemen gilt und auch
durchgesetzt werden kann wir werden uns
jetzt ein paar zentrale Zitate von
russeo ansehen und diskutieren mit Blick
auf diese Frage nach dem Verhältnis von
Individum und Gesellschaft ganz zu
Beginn sagt ruso etwas sehr zentrales er
bemerkt nämlich dass der Mensch
freieboren ist also der Naturzustand so
nenus so diesen ursprünglichen Zustand
der ist so dass der Mensch dort frei ist
so unterscheidet den Naturzustand vom
vernunftzustand der vernunftzustand ist
der Zustand wo es die Wissenschaft sich
entwickelt hat wo es Kultur gibt
das ist die moderne und er ist ein
großer Kritiker der Moderne er sagt die
moderne die modernen Naturwissenschaften
überhaupt alle Form von Wissenschaften
haben uns nicht freier gemacht haben uns
nicht zu besseren Menschen gemacht
sondern es sind dadurch gerade große
Probleme entstanden wie etwa dasjenige
dass wir kein natürliches Mitgefühl kein
Mitleid mehr gegenüber anderen Menschen
auf natürliche Weise zeigen können der
Neid ist durch die moderne in die Welt
gekommen wir verrechnen alles
miteinander wir denken nur instrumentell
wir gebrauchen andere Menschen als
Mittel zum Zweck wir haben nur noch eine
eigigen Liebe ähm ähm also es ist sehr
sehr schwierig in dieser neuen Zeit in
dieser Zeit des vernunftzustandes ähm
und unsere Freiheit droht gerade durch
die moderne gefährdet zu werden und
jetzt sagt der Mensch ist zwar frei
geboren doch liegt überall in Ketten das
heißt obwohl wir ursprünglich frei sind
gelingt es uns nicht Gesellschaftsform
zu entwickeln zu etablieren indem wir
diese natürliche Freiheit bewahren
können hier gibt's ein Problem
natürliche Freiheit scheint sich nicht
zu vertragen mit politischen Systemen
und das möchte Rus jetzt gerade
herausfinden wie können wir natürliche
Freiheit mit politischen Systemen so
vereinbaren dass Freiheit vergrößert
wird und nicht eingeschränkt wird das
ist die spannende Frage die sich ihm
hier
stellt Freiheit ist für ruso ganz
wichtig er sagt auf seine Freiheit
verzichten heißt auf seine Eigenschaft
als Mensch auf seine Menschenrechte
sogar auf seine Pflichten verzichten
also die Freiheit macht den Menschen
erst zu Mensch sie macht sein Wesen aus
ein solcher Verzicht auf Freiheit sagt
er ist unverzichtbar mit der Natur des
Menschen seinem Willem jegliche Freiheit
nehmen heißt seinen Handlungen jegliche
Sittlichkeit nehmen natürlich auch
jegliche würde wir verlieren unsere
würde wenn uns unsere Freiheit genommen
ist müssen noch genauer drauf eingehen
was überhaupt hier mit Freiheit gemeint
ist ja ganz wichtig ist jetzt die Frage
nach der Übereinkunft wie wir uns im
sozialen Kontext darauf einigen auf ein
politischees System in dem unsere
Freiheit gerade bewahrt wird ja und hier
ist eben das Problem dass der Mensch
immer ein Privatinteresse hat ähm und
dass diese Privatinteressen der
verschiedenen Menschen nur schwer unter
einen Hut gebracht werden können häufig
ist die Wahl die Entscheidung in
kollektiven so dass sich manche
durchsetzen dann immer auf Kosten der
Minderheit ja also hier ähm ist das
Problem dass die Frage sich stellt woher
haben 100t die einen Herrn wollen das
rcht für zehn zu stimmen die keinen
wollen das Gesetz der Stimmenmehrheit
beruht selbst auf Übereinkunft und setzt
zum zumindest einmal Einstimmigkeit
voraus also wir müssen uns fragen bevor
wir überhaupt an die Frage nach der
Herrschaft
gehen wie überhaupt Gesellschaft
zustande kommen kann was ist der wahre
Grund die wahre Grundlage der
Gesellschaft wie können wir uns
politisch überhaupt formieren diese
Frage stellt er hier und ganz zentral
wird jetzt hier seine Theorie des
Gesellschaftsvertrages der
Gesellschaftsvertrag deutet dass wir
durch
Zusammenschluss eine Summe von Kräften
bilden die Stärke ist als jener
Widerstand nämlich als Individuum zu
bleiben und diese aus einem einzigen
Antrieb einzusetzen und gemeinsam wirken
zu lassen das ist die Frage was ist
dieser einzige Antrieb der uns
dazu treibt als Gemeinschaft und nicht
nur als Individuum politisch zu
existieren ja er spricht davon dass die
Summe von Kräften nur durch das
Zusammenwirken von mehren entstehen
können wie muss jetzt aber dieses
Zusammenwirken genau gedacht werden hier
hatte eine interessante Formel finde
eine Form des Zusammenschlusses die mit
ihrer ganzen gemeinsamkraft die Person
und das Vermögen jedes einzeln Mitglieds
verteidigt und schützt und durch die
doch jeder indem er sich mit allem
vereinigt nur sich selbst Gehäust und
genauso bleibt wie zuvor das ist
sozusagen das Rätsel die Herausforderung
anders als bei Thomas Hobbs wie können
wir eine Gemeinschaft bilden eine starke
Form des Zusammenschlusses ohne dabei
unsere Freiheit aufgeben zu müssen ja im
Gegenteil wie kann dieser politische
Zusammenschluss ein Ausdruck meiner
Freiheit sein diese Freiheit nennt rusau
Autonomie das ist Autonomie das ist die
Selbstgesetzgebung an die natürlich dann
auch Immanuel Kant angeknüpft hat er hat
diese Theorie dieses Zusammenschlusses
durch den
Gesellschaftsvertrag genauer analysiert
genauer begründet und wir sehen uns
gleich noch genauer an wie das
funktioniert hier spricht davon dass die
Bestimmungen dieses Vertrags durch die
Natur des Aktes nämlich der Konstitution
des Vertrages durch die gemeinsame
Einigung so zu verstehen ist dass sie
immer in Kraft
ist jeder sagt er muss in seine
ursprünglichen Rechte eintreten und
seine natürliche Freiheit wieder
erlangen das ist das entscheidende wir
dürfen nicht unsere natürlich Freiheit
verlieren wenn wir in einen
gesellschaftlichen Konsens in ein
gesellschaftliches System
eintreten ein weiteres zentrales Zitat
bringt jetzt hier seinen Begriff des
gemeinwillens ins Spiel er sagt
folgendes gemeinsam stellen wir alle
jeder von uns und seine Person und seine
ganze Kraft unter die oberste richtschur
des gemeinwillens und wir nehmen als
Körper jedes Glied als untrennbaren Teil
des Ganzen auf hier fühlt man sich
erinnert an Thomas HBS und seine Figur
des leviatan der spricht ganz ähnlich
dass Personen nur Glieder sind dieses
großen Leibes der Unterschied ist aber
der dass wir dadurch nach Rü so gerade
nicht uns aufgeben als freies Wesen
sondern eben gerade unsere Freiheit
bewahren vielleicht sogar noch
vergrößern hier ist jetzt wichtig der
gemeinwille der gemeinwille muss
unterschieden werden vom Wille aller der
Wille aller sind die partikulären
Interessen die Interessen von allen die
wir in einen großen Topf werfen können
und durch das nichts wirklich
einheitliches herauskommt die Interessen
streben in verschiedene Richtungen da
ziehen nicht alle amselben Strang das
ist dann häufig so ein schlechter
Kompromiss der dabei herauskommt von dem
man häufig sagt das ist aber nicht
dasjenige was ich eigentlich will und
der gemeinwil ist jetzt gerade dasjenige
was jedes vernünftige Wesen im Grunde
immer schon will das heißt ist ein recht
idealisierter Wille das muss man dazu
sagen es ist jetzt nicht ein konkreter
Wille der irgendwas konkretes will
sondern es ist eher ein genereller Wille
der uns als vernünftiges Wesen
beschreibt und dadurch sagt jetzt R so
dass alle Wesen in einem solchen
Gesellschaftsvertrag ihren identischen
Gemeinwillen ausgedrückt sehen brauchen
Sie keine Sorge mehr zu haben dass
dadurch ihre Freiheit verloren geht
sondern sofern sie Ausdruck ihres
eigentlichen willens ist werden sie
gerade dadurch
frei ja das ist ein ganz zentraler
Begriff gewesen der
gemeinwille der findet auch in anderen
Theorien immer wieder Anknüpfung wir
haben gesehen dass John rolls die Idee
des vertrages aufnimmt wir werden auch
in den weiteren Sendungen immer mal
wieder auf Rus zurückkommen ein ganz
zentraler Denker der den Gedanken der
Autonomie der Selbstgesetzgebung wie er
sich z.B dann bei Immanuel Kant findet
vorwegenommen hat vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit bis zu einer nächsten
Sendung